[Music]
hello and welcome to i'd like to know
this is really one of our favorite
programs of all the programs done here
at secrets unsealed because we get to
answer your questions we get to
interface with you we get to talk about
the things of the lord we get to study
the word of the lord and we just have a
good time doing so i am ca murray i'm in
the presence of our founder and speaker
pastor stephen bohr and
the new kid on the block this is pastor
daniel miranda and he has become a great
part of the family already we love him
we love his knowledge of the word we
love the spirit that he brings and so
together we have two have become three
and uh we kind of like it this way amen
uh having three preachers of the word
together we make you this promise
if you send in a question we will try to
answer that question we will answer the
question from the word of god if an
answer can be found we will find it but
we'll always give you what the bible has
to say not the traditions of men not our
own personal opinion we want to give you
the word of god because we are so late
in this earth's history that you don't
need to waste time hearing the opinions
of men you need to hear a word from the
lord and that is what we pledge to give
you each and every time you send in a
question should you like to do just that
we invite you to send your questions to
uh
questions or rather
tv tv there you go tv at some tv.org tv
at some tv.org i've got so many emails
and things running around in my brain i
forget sometimes it is tv at some tv.org
should you do that we will get to your
question now we have an impressive stack
of questions do we not we do so we may
not get to it right away but we will get
to it so we encourage you to keep on
watching us each week we'll get to your
question and we'll do the very best we
can to answer it pastor boy if you would
lead us in prayer we've got
a group of questions that we want to
launch into
just after you pray
father in heaven
our human wisdom is limited
that's why we need wisdom from on high
amen and so as we begin this q and a
session we ask for the guidance of your
holy spirit yes help us lord to answer
the questions expeditiously
and with your word as the foundation
amen amen and we thank you for the
promise of your presence through the
spirit and we claim that promise
in the precious and holy name of jesus
amen amen amen amen
one of the things that
we are pleased to note is that we are
getting questions pastor literally from
all over the world
we are getting them from the far east
we're getting them from europe we're
getting them from the con country
continent of africa we're getting them
from south america and of course here in
the united states which says a number of
things uh things one is that the the
word of god is being preached and is
being received all over the world amen
that people all over the world pastor
daniel are hungry for the word and have
questions amen and uh that that's a good
thing because there are answers in the
word of god for these questions i'm
going to throw out this very first one
which comes from amal
and
let's say good day pastor
i have a question that i would like some
light on i've gone through the study
through a study that says god created
adam by speaking
not the traditional way we used to
believe
uh that he gathered dirt etc to make the
body can you send some light on this and
he thanks us
alrighty
okay
well um
i think that
the question is pretty straight or
actually i would say the answer to this
because the bible is very clear in
regards to how god created man and
we go to genesis chapter 2 verse 7
we read clearly that god created man out
of the dust of the earth
and breathed into his nostrils the
breath of life and man became a living
soul
now actually what god used was
clay
in isaiah 64 verse 8 the bible says that
let me read it for you i'm reading from
the king james version
isaiah 64 verse 8 but now o lord
thou art our father we are the clay
and thou are
our potter and we all are the work of
thy hand so it is clear that
god created us from the
from clay from the dust on the ground
and not just by speaking yes i think
that what you just ended is the most
important point pastor the fact that
the creation of man was different than
the creation of the rest of of of the
world the animate and inanimate objects
that god created there was a personal
aspect to the creation of man
we see the creation story in genesis 1
but then it's fleshed out a little more
in genesis 2. we get a little more
detail
in genesis 2. and one of the things we
see is that god
gathered materials together and then
animated it by breathing into this
formed image the breath of life which is
not something that he did in the rest of
creation that was by fiat but there was
a very personal aspect in the creation
of mankind so god had was personally
involved in the creation of man in a way
that he was not in the creation of the
other parts of the world yeah and
actually
death is the opposite of creation true
when it comes to the body because
you know god said to adam in genesis 3
verse 19
to dust you will return
and in ecclesiastes chapter 12 and verse
7 a very well-known verse that is almost
always read in evangelism
it says then the dust will return to the
earth that as it was and the spirit will
return to god who gave it yes
so
clearly man is composed of dust you know
this because when a person is cremated
all you have is a bunch of ashes yes so
man you know once the water is consumed
all that is left is the dust
god used wet
dust which we call potter's clay
and he says we are the work of your
hands so how somehow god's hands were
involved in the process indeed that's
the personal touches
yes um one line from patriots and
prophets page 45.
ellen white says as man came from the
hand of the creator i just took that one
line that says so much one that man came
from the hand of the creator that god
was personally involved and that he was
involved in a way that he was not in any
other part of creation there's a
personal aspect and of course that we
see that all the way through to to the
end when i was at the ephesus church i
preached and i think i've told you this
before
117 funerals
in seven years that's a lot of funerals
i'm not sure i would want to belong to
your church
i said earth to earth to ashes so many
times
i knew that but we did 117 funerals at
at the same church luckily we had
aggressive evangelism or i'd had a net
loss but
the point is uh
re uh affirming what you said that that
death is the reverse of what happened at
creation it is body plus the breath of
god that equals a living soul and then
it is reversed the other way so god is
very personally involved with mankind
another thing that i might mention is
that in terms of material composition
animals
also are composed of dust
and they also have spirit or breath of
life
so what distinguishes
human beings from animals if they both
have
you know material substance
and they also have the spirit i like to
use this illustration
a refrigerator is a material object
isn't it composed of matter
as is a computer
right
now do you need to plug in a
refrigerator in order for the
refrigerator to be energized so to speak
yes do you need to plug in the computer
for the computer to be energized very
much yet would we say that the computer
is much more sophisticated than the
refrigerator
the brain of the refrigerator yes you
know they both have to be plugged in
they both are compel
composed of material substance
but
the hardware yes that god put in them
is different
so so you know even though animals are
composed of dust and they have spirit or
breath yes
human beings and animals are different
very much so there is a moral component
that makes us more like god that animals
do not have
so it's a good question and uh we thank
you amal for it
now the second question is this the seth
question this is one with the many parts
yes yes yes
seth and i would not even
try to pronounce this last name
g-b-a-f-a-h
yeah it's a it's a buffer
[Laughter]
i probably massacred the name but seth
is writing and uh dear sir and he's got
he's got several questions and when we
looked at these these are kind of fun
questions because the bible does not go
deep into this kind of thing and a lot
of this is speculative some of these
there is no answer for but um
let's take a look at them uh
question number one what was the name of
lot's wife see we we answered the very
deep and very serious and we answered
the little lighter questions too name of
lot's wife two name of job's wife three
how old was adam and eve when god made
them
and some of these are almost kind of
trick questions four how many disciples
did john the baptist have and five what
is the name of john the baptist's
disciples okay
one and two lot's wife job's wife
daniel well the bible doesn't give us
that information but uh
as we were
talking earlier we could call them
mrs mrs lord and mrs joe
that's probably the best that we can do
that's that's about the best we can do
mrs lot this is joe other than that we
do not find any extra biblical uh
information that i know
in regards to their
names
even jesus himself
when he mentioned lot's wife he didn't
say the name he remember lot's wife yes
yes yes
you know sometimes the bible gives us
detail down to very fine detail other
times it keeps keeps it broad because
the the name of the person may not be as
important as what god's interaction with
them represents
how god responded to them how they
responded to god and the lessons that we
can learn from their intercourse with
with the lord may be much more important
than the name itself true
so how old were
how old were adam and eve when god made
them were they were infants were they
children
were they old were they in the prime of
you so what can we say about that does
the bible give us any indications
the only indication that that we have is
that they were they were they were adult
they were grown they were they were old
enough to be married
right good points
and all that that entailed yeah and he
had to be old enough to be wise enough
to name the animals too indeed indeed
indeed
so they weren't they weren't children
they were not not uh infants um they
were they were adults
yeah
now how many disciples did john the
baptist have i'm not sure that we have
that uh
information in the bible unless i've
missed it yeah well from from the
records we find we have in the gospels
at least we know four
four disciples right
two of them john and andrew they were
his disciples then we have the other two
that he sent
when he asked jesus if he was the
messiah or if he was waiting for another
one but those are the four that i have
found in the bible
yeah probably he had more yeah probably
he had more but
you're right that's all the bible has to
tell us about the disciples of john
and two of them became disciples of
jesus jesus yes there there seems to be
a fairly decent number
some of the the things that ellen white
says um she talks about john's disciples
in trying to encourage him we're
actually discouraging him you know she
says sometimes our friends can try to
say things to encourage us but they're
really right they were saying you know
john you were you used to be like a big
guy but now this other guy's come and
your disciples are leaving you and
they're going after him you know and
they weren't really helping the
situation at all you know they were
trying to say some things to encourage
him but they were not
and so
she says we need to be careful of the
kind of incursion what we say to other
individuals because sometimes we can we
can feed into their weaknesses as
opposed to supporting them in the
strength john was was already depressed
he was a country guy he was in the city
not it was in the city he was in prison
he's wondering about his life he's
looking at the shift from his ministry
to to uh to christ's ministry ellen
white says he was as as great apostles
he was he he had the mistaken belief
that christ was going to come and free
them from the romans like everybody else
had so what the disciples were telling
him what his fellow
followers were telling him was not
encouraging to him at all in fact it was
discouraging him because he was he was
hoping to get out of prison he realized
after all he was not going to but it was
it was tough on him to be in prison
because he was a country guy christ was
a city guy who spent most of his time in
galilee john was a country guy who spent
a lot of his time in jerusalem so they
were reversed in their ministries and
illinois says christ uh the christ kept
it that way so that his ministry
wouldn't sort of stumble over john and
john over him but it was tough on john
because uh he wasn't going to be free he
was never going to get out of prison
you know the thing that really
i admire about john the baptist
is his humility yes
you know he said i'm not worthy to talk
to tie the sandal straps
of the one that comes after me
and he did seem to be threatened by the
idea that some of his disciples became
the disciples of jesus
so
you know he he was
he was an individual who really had his
priorities straight yeah he knew what
his role was his role was to be
the progenitor of the messiah in other
words his role was to prepare the way
for the messiah and then he was to fade
into the woodwork yes yes it was a it
was a testament to his love for the lord
ellen white says satan visited him in
that prison whispering things in his
ears you know you should be out of here
you really shouldn't be here uh christ
is freeing this person healing this
person doing this how come he's leading
you here to suffer you know and to to
pain can can play with your head you
know it can do when you're you can't be
free and you can't see the sun and you
can't move
you're locked in this prison experience
you don't know what's going to happen
you really have to lock on to jesus and
hold on to what you know to be truth to
make it through those times and he did
so he never gave up of his faith he
never turned away from jesus but he had
some he had some doubts but that happens
when you're in pain for a long period of
time but christ knows and understands
that amen the spirit of prophecy tells
us that john and jesus were cousins
you know so they were relatives yes
interestingly enough yeah about six
months apart i think uh but we praise
the lord for for his
faith and his stamina
in the face of
you know terrible circumstances
uh we know the name of two and uh that
pretty much takes care of those
questions and we thank seth for for for
those questions pastor i want to turn
this one over to you it's kind of long
and um maybe you want to sort of wade
your way through it and then we'll we'll
try to tackle it
okay this is a question from john
i hope i'm pronouncing his probably his
middle name estarike
itanjishaka
hope i didn't massacre that name
this is the question my question talks
about the attitude needed when you are
praying
why don't many pastors obey the
statement of l g white
written in selected messages volume 2
chapter 32
and so then he quotes it and i think
i'll just go ahead and quote it i have
received letters questioning me
in regard to the proper attitude to be
taken by a person offering prayer to the
sovereign of the universe
where have our brethren obtain the idea
that they should stand upon their feet
when praying to god
one who has been educated for about five
years in battle creek was asked to lead
in prayer before sister white should
speak to the people but as i beheld him
standing upright upon his feet while his
lips were about to open in prayer to god
my soul was stirred within me to give
him an open rebuke
calling him by name i said get down upon
your knees
this is the proper position always
then
i present these proof texts with the
inquiry
says the person was asking the question
where did brother h obtain his education
at battle creek
is it possible that with all the light
that god has given to his people on the
subject of reverence that ministers
principals and teachers in our schools
by precept and example teach young men
to stand erect in devotion as to the
pharisees shall we look upon this as
significant of their self-sufficiency
and self-importance are these traits to
become conspicuous conspicuous so is
this statement true or not is it a sin
to pray without kneeling
upon
your
i will should be your knees
okay so daniel what can we say about
that
when when we studied that the subject of
prayer both the attitude and and the
demeanor in prayer
we need to go beyond the principle of
what prayer is i mean prayer is more
than just a position
just it's more than merely kneeling
because we can kneel and yet have the
wrong spirit when we're praying it is
true that the bible
tends to emphasize more
kneeling as the correct posture when we
are praying
we have several references that i have
here i won't read them but i'll just
quote them luke 22 41
uh in regards to jesus acts 9 40 acts 7
59 and 60 acts 20 36 acts 20 21 5.
we also have it in ezra 9 6 etc we have
many examples in the bible
that
prayers were of made
kneeling
now when we
read
the writings of ellen white we see other
instances where she herself
prayed standing yes and um
we have some
for example
here
when she made a in an alto call a
congregation a prayer prayer for
consecration
i invited it says here all who wanted to
give themselves to god in a sacred
covenant and to serve him with their
whole hearts to rise to their feet
the house was full and nearly all roast
quite a number
not of our faith were present and some
of these arose i presented them to the
lord in earnest prayer and we know that
we had the manifestation of the spirit
of god we felt that a victory had indeed
been been gained so we see here sister
white inviting the congregation to stand
and she offered the prayer also standing
so
it is true that
this position uh inspires more reverence
but at the same time we cannot be so
caught up with the position and
and then
judging
others who might not prayer pray
kneeling
saying that they're sinning because
actually
sin goes beyond a simple formality in in
regards to position of prayer
one of the things that
one of the texts you mentioned and
sparked something in my mind in luke 18
10 we have the the two men who went into
the temple to pray
one of the things that that parable
makes very plain to us is that whether
your prayer is heard or not has a lot to
do with the attitude that you come
before god with
two men went in to pray one was heard
one was not why because of the attitude
that they came to god
with
the truth is
the best thing to do is kneel in
reverence for god
the corresponding truth is
you can't always kneel
i remember leaving when i was dating
irma as a winter storm when i was
driving and i i hit a patch of ice in
the car spun around backwards and i
prayed i didn't have time to kneel you
know
i didn't have time to address god just
like okay lord help you know and the car
spun around and it slid right between
two trees into a snow bank no dents no
nothing
i know that prayer was heard amen also i
didn't have any money i left my wallet
at irma's and the guy who came along
happened to know me and he pulled me out
of the ditch so i know the lord was in
charge and i had no time to pray or to
get formal oh father which are in heaven
you know the car's doing this i don't
have time for that so it's it's the
attitude the sincerity that you bring
along with your presence before the lord
kneeling is is good and is best and is
right but it's not always possible right
you know many times when i'm laying in
bed i pray
you know the bible sustains you know
that david and others who prayed while
they were laying on their bed
you know when you're driving
sometimes you know when you when you
meet obstacles or your car
kind of sputters or something you raise
a prayer to the lord yes doesn't mean
that you kneel
i think however that ellen white when
she
uses these quotations she is referring
primarily
to the worship service
i don't think she's referring to the
prayers you know when you have an
emergency like you or or a prayer you
know in your bed when you're reflecting
upon the lord i think she's talking
about the maybe the invocation in the
worship service you know the pastoral
prayer which is the prayer that is
offered by
and generally by the head elder of the
church
you know those are always prayers where
we kneel
in church and um you know if i can read
psalm 95
um
this is a psalm that we used to read
every sabbath for the 20 years that i
preached
actually let out in fresno central
church
it says
and this is in the context of worship
um
all come let us worship and bow down
let us kneel
before the lord our maker
so and it's speaking in a worship
context so i think that we need to take
into account the place that we're at the
environment yeah as well amen
yeah basically the
the issue with this question is has to
do more
with uh the worship service
um
i have gotten i have received these
questions many times
actually i was at a certain place and
i was used to when when you were singing
the
introductory hymn and then you offer the
the initial prayer usually that one is
standing and then the pastoral prayer is
kneeling depends on the churches i was
doing i was going to do it standing and
and later i was rebuked because of that
so
we can we can go to a to an extreme of
being very very picky about that right
and uh and losing the spirit and the
attitude as you said uh in prayer now we
can become critical critical of others
and i just wonder if it's not a sin to
be critical of yes yes uh you know this
the parable that you mentioned the
pharisee and the public
you know the public and was i also
standing um
[Laughter]
it says in luke chapter 18
uh so the republican obviously did not
believe that he had to kneel every time
that he prayed because it says there in
uh let's begin with verse 11 the
pharisees stood
and prayed thus with himself god i thank
you that i am not like other men
extortioners unjust adulterers or even
as this tax collector i fast twice a
week i give tithes of all that i possess
see it's all about the attitude
and the tax collector standing afar off
would not so much as raised his eyes to
heaven but beat his breath saying god be
merciful to me a sinner so both of them
were standing
but the difference between them was
their attitude
like you were mentioning yeah yeah i
think everything when you come to the
lord has to do with attitude you can you
can be very high in the church and have
a bad attitude you can stand in a pulpit
with a bad attitude and um if your
attitude is wrong your prayers will not
be right regardless of the position that
your body is in it's what's in your
heart uh even more than than how your
your body is standing or sitting amen
amen
well i don't think we have time to
answer the next question because it uh
has uh about eight questions
so we're gonna have to save that one for
next time
uh but um you know maybe we can just
mention anchor uh a little bit here
you know our anchor school of theology
this year is going to be in denver
colorado i mean this coming year 2022
go to our website to look for the
information
this year we are going to
look for all of the seventh-day
adventist beliefs in the four gospels in
the book of acts that's going to be the
foundation
and it's especially for those christians
who say well i'm a new testament
christian you know adventists they are
based on the old testament well we're
going to show that all of the teachings
of the adventist church are found
in the four gospels in the book of acts
so i'm really looking forward to that
you know people can register they can
come in person or they can actually
watch online
but i thought it would be a good
opportunity to let people know about
this so that they plan ahead yeah and
this is going to be an exciting one and
and when the pastor says plan ahead plan
ahead do so because the the denverites
are saying they're going to fill us up
so if you want to get a seat you need to
plan early and get your registration in
because the people from denver are going
to show up on mass and we're going to be
glad to receive them well our time is
fast slipped into eternity we'll see you
again next time remember keep studying
the word keep praying and we'll see you
again god bless
[Music]
you